alors je te raconte l'histoire de
casimir premier d'accord vous y allez
venez venez vite je vous la raconte
vous êtes là aussi eh bien ça tombe bien
je vous racontais à vous aussi
l'histoire de l'ancêtre de casimir qui
fut élu roi des animaux de l'île sous le
nom de casimir premier à cette époque
lag très très longtemps il ya 7 millions
d'années au moins la terre était envahi
de gigantesques bêtes des diplodocus des
dinosaures des brontosaures et bien
d'autres dans l'île aux enfants qui à
cette époque là ça fait simplement lille
s'est pas encore l'île aux enfants
yvette une tribu de tyrannosaure
c'étaient les plus grands et les plus
méchants c'était des reptiles carnassier
il mesurait 15 mètres de long il avait
cinq mètres de haut et leur tête avaient
un mètre quarante il terrorisait tous
les autres animaux de l'île et
quelquefois il dévorait tout simplement
non loin de là vivait une famille de nos
très gentils très doux qui l'ennuyait
personnes et qui tient un petit peu
bizarre il était beaucoup plus petits ne
beaucoup plus intelligents que les
tyrannosaures et s'agaçait beaucoup ces
derniers un jour tous les animaux de
l'île se réunissent et viennent voir le
grand père casimir us le chef de la
famille et lui disent écoutez ça peut
plus durer comme ça il faut il faut
absolument faire quelque chose chassez
ces féroces tyrannosaure de lille
le grand père accepte tout de suite
admiration chez les autres animaux de
l'île qui l'applaudissent le grand père
casimir us se rend chez le chef
tyrannosaures et 8 il mon cher demain je
vous invite à manger une viande
succulentes que vous n'avez encore
jamais mangé et attention très très
malin le grand-père ce qu'il avait fait
il était venu après le déjeuner du chef
tyrannosaure celui ci bien vite viande
n'avais plus envie de se précipiter
dessus une nouvelle fronde que je
connais pas eh ben c'est entendu je me
rendrai mais attention si jamais je
connais cette viande voulait casimir us
les uns après les autres je vous mange
tous le grand père casimir s'accepte
mehdi attention moi aussi je pose une
condition
moi aussi si cette viande vous ne la
connaissez pas eh bien vous les
tyrannosaures demain vous débarrassez
tous lille
entendu le festin s'organise tout le
monde met la main à la pâte dans une
clairière
on dresse une estrade car il fallait
absolument donner une atmosphère de fête
m le chef tyrannosaure en confiance on
dresse une estrade pour un casimir
chanteur et 3 casimir us danseuse la
maman kaysing russell fait un énorme
point que les castings russe à l'époque
manger avec des murs du poisson fumé et
des fraises sauvages délicieux paraît-il
elle mais ça de côté
le chef tyrannosaure arrive très
orgueilleux est revenue sans arrêt son
immense que qui mesurait près de sept
mètres de long et dont il était très
fier
il s'installe
le spectacle commence le casimir us
chanteur et les casimir us danseuses sur
l'estrade évolué et chante il n'avait
jamais vu ça et bailly émerveillé
sidéris complètement hypnotisé y regarde
ça c'est ce qu'avait prévu le grand père
casimir us avec l'aide de ses deux fils
il passe derrière
il attrape le morceau de que tu chef
tyrannosaure il le met entre les deux
morceaux de pain puis sandwich il
apporte devant le chai tyrannosaure
quand le chef vois ça il se précipite
dessus il ouvre la bouche et il donne un
grand coup de dent les hurlements qu'il
fit entendre firent trembler toute l'île
le premier roman fut bien sûr à
hurlements de douleur
le deuxième hurlements fut un hurlement
de dépit parce qu'il avait perdu son
pari le troisième hurlements futa
hurlements de honte parce qu'il avait
perdu un grand morceau de la queue dont
il était si fier et le quatrième
hurlements fusent à hurlements de colère
qu'à rentrer chez lui tous les autres
tyrannosaur ce mot car de lui parce
qu'il avait perdu un morceau tu as que
le lendemain les tyrannosaures avait
disparu de l'île à tout jamais quelle
joie chez les animaux de l'île sur le
champ ils élisent le grand père casimir
us roi des animaux de l'île sous le
titre de casimir premier et depuis cette
époque à travers des millions et des
millions d'années les casimir us sont
restés pour toutes les autres espèces de
l'île des modèles de courage
et voilà c'était l'histoire du gaz et
des premiers
au port ce coup casimir secours casimir
qu'est ce qui t'arrive dégagé dégagé à
nous écraser cas ça me fait quelque
chose mais quoi
il y as depuis un quart d'heure une
souris blanches ski team poursuit